then our friend alexander dugin people  claim that alexander is now  quote-unquote the most dangerous  philosopher of our time and will  discover if that's true yes or no  the concept of liberty where this that  we are discussing  was from the beginning negative concept  so that liberty  that was deliberately from that was  defined by mills  and idea because if you  suggest that you are free for something  you limit you limit by that the freedom  itself so it is contradictory  this is one side of the point uh  freedom from  but there's also freedom too  that is at the heart of the definition  freedom to speak  freedom to think  freedom to assemble freedom to worship  or not worship  freedom to  do as you like until  your own choice conflicts with someone  else's freedom and then the government  is there structures are there a process  is there to try to help regulate